I'm Dr Natalie Chang neurologist and
assistant professor of clinical
neurology I'm here today to answer your
questions from the internet this is
nerve support
[Music]
at Emily flower asks if your brain
doesn't have any sensory nerves that's
why you can be awake during a brain
surgery then what the heck are headaches
it's true that the brain does not have
any sensory nerves it has no pain
receptors many other structures in the
head and neck do so the meninges which
is the covering of the brain as well as
the blood vessels in the head and the
muscles in the head and neck all have
pain fibers these can all be affected
when you have a headache at Kelly Shakur
us why do they call it a funny bone
ain't nothing funny about hitting that
the funny bone sensation is when you
actually hit the ulnar nerve which is
pretty superficial right here as it
comes around the medial epicondyle of
your upper arm bone most people think
that it's called the funny bone because
it feels funny when you hit it but it's
actually a really bad dad joke from the
19th century this bone is called the
humerus and some people thought back
then that instead of calling it the
humerus they call it the funny bone at
CoCo Noir ass why do our limbs fall
asleep nation of our limbs falling
asleep is called paresthesias that pins
and needle sensation when we've
compressed a peripheral nerve for too
long and what happens isn't really that
the blood flow has stopped to that limb
it's more that that nerve can't send
those electrical signals back to the
brain to tell them that there's feeling
in that limb when you stop that
compression of that nerve like when you
wake up and you feel that pins and
needles it's really the electrical
signals kind of going crazy because
they're like oh finally we're no longer
being compressed at erlen henriquez ass
so how does general anesthesia work
general anesthesia is actually one of
the great Modern Marvels of medicine and
really laid the foundation for surgery
as we know it today before general
anesthesia if you had to have let's say
a limb amputated you were awake you
could see everything and there was
really not much pain control now you
would undergo general anesthesia which
is made up of several components so
number one is being unconscious number
two is not remembering any anything
three is pain control four is
maintaining your body's functions while
you're out and then lastly we want to
make sure that you have muscle
relaxation and paralysis you can imagine
all these things are important because
if a surgeon is operating on you you
don't want a moving patient you also
don't want a muscle to be really rigid
you really don't want to smell your
burning flesh at Kelly hogaboom us is
the sympathetic versus parasympathetic
nerve system concept real and also if so
what is the difference in terms I can
understand reference I am like a Wily
but well-meaning caveman well
well-meaning caveman imagine a
saber-toothed tiger is running after you
and you need to respond the sympathetic
nervous system is part of the autonomic
nervous system and it helps mediate your
automatic functions like breathing heart
rate sweating and digestion if the saber
tooth tiger is chasing you you want your
heart rate to go up so that blood can
get to all the organs in your body you
want the arteries that Supply your
muscles to dilate so that you can run
away from the saber-toothed tiger and
you really don't want to send blood to
your gastrointestinal system because now
is not the time to digest that food that
you just ate in contrast the
parasympathetic nervous system is more
our rest and digest or feed and breed
functioning and this is where digestion
becomes a priority as well as
reproduction at Dunkel uglis ass is the
nervous system what causes anxiety
because my system is freaking nervous
technically yes the nervous system does
promote the actual feeling of anxiety so
fast heart rate trouble breathing kind
of queasiness in our gastrointestinal
system this is a fight or flight
response being activated now when people
have anxiety this response is on all the
time which can be pretty taxing for our
minds our bodies as well as our emotions
at mohosa official asks about how fast
do nerve impulses travel Action
potentials can travel as quickly as 100
meters per second which is about 200 124
miles per hour for us non-metric system
users they can travel more quickly if
the nerve is covered in myelin myelin
acts like insulation just like on an
electrical wire that helps the impulse
travel more quickly instead of having
the electrical signal travel
continuously down it can jump in between
these fatty segments at film car stairs
S I want to know how I can move my body
like how can my brain send signals to my
toes and tell them to move I don't get
it the way your body moves is through a
system called the cortical spinal tract
and this is a big part of your motor
systems let's say you want to move your
toes our brain actually has a map of the
body in the motor cortex and there is a
toe Center actually here in the middle
that will then send a signal to the
spinal cord it sends fibers to your
spinal cord on the opposite side of the
body it crosses in the medulla which is
at the base of your brain stem at
saphrodite ass the nervous system is so
weird like what is itching itching is
pretty annoying but it's a pretty smart
defensive mechanism so let's say you
have a mosquito who's crawling on your
arm you definitely want to know about
that so that you can hopefully flick it
away and it doesn't bite you this is
sort of like a pain response but it kind
of tickles but that's what itching's
purpose is at Jenna TS why can we be
tickled like what response is that
tickling is a type of itch almost and we
found that when people have done
functional neuroimaging studies of the
brain while being tickled that two areas
light up so the somatosensory cortex
lights up when you're being tickled so
that's our touch processing center but
also the anterior cingulate cortex which
is right here and this is our emotional
Center so there definitely is a touch
but also emotional component to being
tickled in terms of why we laugh when
we're tickled some think it's a form of
social bonding like between a baby and
its parent and others think it's more of
a sign of submission to your Tickler
that you're done being tickled and
they've won at Melody b123s the
difference between central nervous
system and peripheral nervous system is
confusing me and I think it's meant to
be straightforward the central nervous
system includes your brain and spinal
cord the peripheral nervous system is
basically anything that is outside of
the skull or outside of the spinal
column so in this diagram the peripheral
nervous system starts basically where
these branches come off the spinal cord
and you can see more peripheral nerves
in the limbs here and here at Kagan
Ellen asks does acupuncture work for
chronic pain yes about 39 clinical
trials found that doing acupuncture
significantly improved the control of
chronic pain at just Doza s why does
pain have to be so painful you know so
pain is a really smart defense mechanism
by our bodies to avoid things that might
potentially injure the body permanently
like if you step on a nail you don't
want to keep walking on that foot
because every time you step down you're
injuring your foot further it's a signal
to you to fix whatever is is hurting you
so that you prevent further damage at
Prof cooler asks how do nerves
regenerate nerves in the peripheral
nervous system can regenerate and what
happens is let's say there's some injury
to a nerve the immune system is
activated and it's kind of like New
Year's Day in Times Square the cleaning
crew comes up and just gets rid of all
that debris until that debris is cleaned
up the cell body in the main part of the
neuron can't really give out directions
to produce new axon endings at Thigh
Master asks during a physical why does
the doctor tap your knee with a hammer
but when we're testing your reflexes in
the exam room we're checking to see if
your motor and sensory neuron reflex is
intact when we tap your let's say your
patellar tendon that cause causes a
stretch in a muscle spindle this sends a
signal back to the sensory neuron which
activates a motor neuron in the spinal
cord to cause your knee to kick up if
this reflex is absent it could indicate
that you have a lower motor neuron
problem if it's overactive meaning it's
too jumpy it can signal a problem with
an upper motor neuron something in the
spinal cord above the level of the
knee-jerk reflex which is L3 L4 or
something in the brain at e Martin 11s
why do people have such different pain
tolerances pain is actually both a
physical and an emotional phenomenon
it's been studied that various factors
like history of Prior trauma lack of
sleep female sex can give folks lower
pain tolerances higher pain tolerance is
associated with older age exercise
activity as well as more social support
at eat or asks seriously what is carpal
tunnel what are you guys doing with your
wrists I have never suffered this issue
but I'm intrigued so carpal tunnel is
when there's compression of the median
nerve here in your wrist which is where
the carpal tunnel is it's a pretty small
tunnel where the tendons of a lot of the
form our muscles run through as well if
you get any type of repetitive stress
injury like the common one is typing
other people notice it with cooking or
other types of frequent manual labor
they can cause compression of this nerve
at amnon 96s how does local anesthesia
work medications like lidocaine or
xylicane which you typically get at the
dentist or first the minor procedures
basically block the opening of
voltage-gated sodium ions which means
that you can't really have those Action
potentials spread so it really stops
electrical impulses at anesthesia BS
would you fill me in on what brain zaps
are that sounds terrifying so brain zaps
are actually something that's more
recently described in the early 2000s
where people would notice that they
would fill these electrical shocks in
their head or it feels like buzzing we
found that they're associated with
stopping antidepressant medications it's
also been described after people use
ecstasy or stop taking other medications
like benzodiazepines it might be some
change to neurotransmitter levels as
you've stopped taking these medications
but we're still trying to figure out why
they happen at ragde bouillon 31s why do
nerves in the teeth have to exist
freaking toothaches man your teeth are
kind of precious in terms of you know
once you have your permanent teeth you
don't get new ones if you think about it
it's also in the mouth which is where we
put a lot of things that could harm us
right you could eat bad food you could
eat something sharp that could cause a
perforation of your stomach so if
there's a problem with your teeth you
want to know quickly rather than letting
it slowly Decay and potentially cause an
infection those are all the questions
hopefully you learned something today
see you next time
[Music]